si vous avez vu le match de rugby france
springboks samedi à la télé une scène
assez violente ne vous a certainement
pas échappé dans une mêlée confuse un
avants sud-africains dont le nom en tout
cas m'échappe a dressé un terrible
crochet au française sfef qui est
pourtant une armoire à glace et qui est
allé au tapis
cela ne veut pas dire bien sûr que les
springboks se sont des brutes et les
français des agneaux mais cet incident a
montré une fois de plus les mauvaises
habitudes de jouer dur comme l'on dit au
rugby les vilains gestes sont cependant
rares en matches internationaux mais
fréquents en revanche dans le
championnat de france et celle en quête
de georges dominique coups de poing
coups de pied gifle dans le jargon du
rugby on parle aussi de bouffe de
marrons de cravate
un seul de ces mauvais geste suffit
parfois à mettre le feu aux poudres
le résultat un spectacle déplorable de
ce genre forte heureusement de tels
incidents sont rares néanmoins depuis
quelques années on constate une
recrudescence du jeu déloyal
cela en dépit des sanctions de plus en
plus sévères appliquée par la fédération
française de rugby
pourquoi le jeu dur qu'en est il
exactement
joueurs entraîneurs et dirigeants
répondent des choses de lui ça devient
de plus en plus des athlètes et su
atteindre les 800 de plus en plus vite
donc les comme les contacts de plus en
plus mal et c'est un joueur se vexer il
se laisse aller à ses places et gestes
qui sont interdits sur un terrain de
rugby et qui sans vraiment navrant car
je crois que le rugby est un tuyau vente
au 31 pour s'amuser pour se libérer et
il faudrait pas que ça devienne
un jeu trop brutale on n'a plus le droit
de perdre un match à domicile sinon
c'est la catastrophe on n'est plus
qualifié en 16e
l'argent ne rentre plus à partir de là
plus spectateur au sort trop vite en
deuxième division
il faut gagner à tout prix alors les
consignes de certains entraîneurs
peut-être pas tous en scène les
consignes sont le protégaient
mondialisée il faut à tout prix gagner
et si on peut éliminer quelqu'un au fort
d'un avantage est alors éliminé un
adversaire
cela veut dire à avoir la supériorité
mais cette supériorité
on peut aussi la voir un jour oui c'est
certain et c'est ce que nous par exemple
nous cherchons ici puisque nous avons
quand même un idéal de jeu qui
l'attaquent qu'on aime bien et qu'on
espère conserver et je pense qu'on est
beaucoup plus content parce qu on décale
un ailier klaus communément une cravate
l'enjeu est trop grand voilà c'est le
championnat qui le veut et l'enjeu très
grand et on veut gagner à tout prix
alors on laisse des fois même leurs
bidons de lait sur le feu
le rugby quoi pour gagner en formation
pour gagner quoi alors on ne joue pas
plus dur ne jouit pas d'une façon
beaucoup plus dur en beaucoup plus
brutale qu autrefois ce n'est pas vrai
en fait que nous du moins je ne le pense
pas c'est le rythme qui a changé c'est
beaucoup plus plein match
il n'y a pas de trou comme autrefois
avec des longs moments de récupération
soient aux touches soient toutes les
phases statiques
c'est un perpétuel mouvement maintenant
il faut on demandera aux sommes beaucoup
plus de qualités d'athlète qu autrefois
faut pas voir le rugby actuel à travers
le jeu dur c'est une mauvaise image le
rugby c'est quelque chose de merveilleux
il ya des joueurs qui s'amusent
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser il
ya des joueurs qui surtout qu'ils
désirent s'amuser et il sans majorité il
ya des clubs qui ne semble qu'ils ne
pratiquent pas le jeu dur et je pense
que si on se sensibilise sur le problème
du jeu dur c'est justement pour
permettre à ces clubs là de pouvoir
s'exprimer davantage et de donner au
rugby sa véritable image de l'esprit du
du français veut dire toujours
contourner la règle le rugby fait quinze
contre quinze mais si on peut jouer
contre 15 à 14 c'est pas plus mal après
les points français et je trouve que ce
système remplacement de joueur va
arrêter du moins cette hémorragie l'a22
de jeu dur quoi je pense qu'actuellement
les joueurs ne savaient plus amusé nous
l'avons remarqué au dernier bouclier
automne nous ont vu des matches où quand
même quelques joueurs essayer de faire
quelque chose mais nous en vue des
matches je pense assez décevant surtout
compte tenu de la personnalité de la
qualité des joueurs qui étaient sur le
terrain pour moi et je dis à ta sorte de
catégorie à l'entraîneur qui dit à son
équipe il faut gagner à tout prix et
l'éducateur qui doit dire à son équipe
il faut gagner mais en jouant au rugby
et voilà pour moi la grande différence
je ne veux pas dire que tous les
entraîneurs soient mis dans le même sac
et j'en connais qui sont
cette catégorie à bon alors il ya le jeu
depuis lors je leur ai alors il faut le
faire la différence sur formulaire s-1
pas toujours faut bien l'avouer quand
tout parce que l'enjeu est primordial
lorsque sur un terrain l'équipe adverse
joue dur et lui en toi dit que mahmoud
abbas en est on joue dans cet engrenage
vision joueurs entraîneurs ne sont pas
les seuls responsables du jeu dur il ne
faut pas oublier en effet le
comportement parfois inadmissible du
public et le chauvinisme excessif de
certains spectateurs
le problème de la protection des
arbitres préoccupe également la
fédération la saison dernière et l'a
radié à vie deux fois plus de joueurs
pour agression d'un le remède contre le
jeu dur c'est d'abord la sévérité des
sentiers tellement de mise en garde que
l'épée de damoclès est pas nue sur de la
tête de tous les joueurs de tous les
dirigeants
ils savent ce qu'ils risquent maintenant
et tous mes filles et à la peur du jeune
homme qui joue énormément quand on parle
de politique entre le jeu dur que
poursuit d'ailleurs activement la
fédération française de rugby
on se limite à te ment on voit les
arbitres on attend tous des arbitres et
de la commission de discipline je pense
que c'est un faux problème je crois
qu'il faut d'abord faire il faudrait
arriver à créer une prise de conscience
globale de tout de tout le monde du
rugby sur le jeu dur il faudrait que la
politique contre le jeu dur se pratique
au sein même des classes je pense qu'il
faut pas enlever rugby son agressivité
laissez les garçons mais faire jouer
pendant 80 minutes à fond les
sanctionner même à l'intérieur du club
s'ils commettent des actes
répréhensibles je passe vous pour
arriver à assainir leurs aiguilles qui
se passe n'est quand même pas si bas
qu'on le dit d'une façon générale les
britanniques ont des joueurs qui restent
davantage maîtres d'eux-mêmes le jeu et
des fois très viril mais il reste dans
le domaine de la vérité il ya des choses
qui se voir en grande bretagne même
presque pas du tout ce sont des coups de
pied à des joueurs à terre alors que le
ballon est à 20 mètres de là où se
déroulent cet événement il ya des gestes
qui sont inadmissibles dans le rugby par
exemple donné un coup de pied en joueurs
car le joueur est à terre ou même dans
une bagarre c'est inadmissible il
faudrait dire une fois pour toutes que
si ça serait si ça se produit les
joueurs doivent être exclues exclu mais
pas exclu pour un match de match il doit
être suspendu pour une saison et même
éventuellement radié à vie parce que
finalement dans les équipes qui ont la
réputation de pratiquer le jeu dur il ya
combien de joueurs qui pratiquent ce jeu
là bas il y en a deux il y en a 3 yann a
pas d'avantagé des autres aimeraient
jouer au ballon
je pensais c'est lé président vient de
tenir leurs joueurs et d'en charger mais
leurs supporters au niveau de l'équipe
de france nous arrivons à le faire je ne
vois pas pourquoi on n'aurait pas le
faire au mieux leur club elle aurait tué
il s'avère que les sanctions sont pas
suffisantes
absolument pas puisque nous avons en
lisant on pourrait que des arts le même
nombre de garçons qui s'est produit mal
sur un intérêt est par contre sur le
plan international d'avoir dans les
incidents depuis dix ans on pourra
jamais fait aussi bien au niveau
des équipes de a que des équipements
militaires encore le match que nous
avons eues contre l'armée russe
notamment à toulouse et à paris a été
parfait le rugby compte environ 140
milles pratiquants près de 4000 matchs
sont discutées chaque année bilan du jeu
dur la saison dernière un peu plus de
1000 sanctions dont 40 radiation à vie
le jeu dur est donc essentiellement le
fait d'une minorité de joueurs une
minorité qui malheureusement qui relie
le prestige de ce sport merveilleux
spectacle lorsqu'il est bien joué c'est
à dire loyalement